another part of it is what's called role
entrapment that is
a sense that the role you've gotten into
of being a certain kind of a person
starts to entrap you my father told me a
story some years ago
about a tailor in a middle eastern
european country
there was a jewish man wanted to show
that he had done well so he went to the
best tailor in town whose name was
zumbak
and he said zomback i want your best
suit so zomback
made a suit and the man came in to try
on the suit
and he put it on and it was beautiful
material no doubt about it but when he
put it on
this sleeve was about two inches longer
than the sleeve
and he said zomback he said i i don't
mean to complain
but he said this sleeve is two inches
longer than this sleeve
zumback took a front sunbeck says
there's nothing wrong with a suit it's
the way he's standing
stand like this and he pushes his
shoulder down
and the suit then fits perfectly you see
and the man looks in the mirror and he
sees this this big bunched up material
back here and he says
i'm back would you mind taking that my
wife hates it when there's that extra
bunch of material there
somebody says there's nothing wrong with
a suit it's the way you're standing and
he pushes his head down like this
so finally the suit is fitting perfectly
and the man leaves with his new suit on
he's afraid to breathe
fear it won't fit and he's been
completely cowed by zumba
and he gets on the bus and he's standing
on the bus and somebody comes up and
says
what a beautiful suit i bet some back to
taylor made that suit
and the fella said how did you know he
said because only somebody as skilled as
zumback could fit somebody
as crippled as you
[Laughter]
[Music]
now uh the
feeling often of role entrapment
is that you have gotten into a suit and
everybody's saying what a beautiful suit
what a beautiful suit except your spine
is out of whack and you're feeling
inside not the same not as good in my